BMW has brought out the third-generation
of the x5 the big SUV or SAV for a
sports activity vehicle and BMW Paulo's
has been of the company's lineup for 14
years now and figured strongly in the
trend towards sporty all-terrain
vehicles almost all models come with
BMWs xDrive all-wheel drive as standard
equipment
now BMW has added a rear-wheel drive
diesel option the full-color heads-up
display features new data content
then I X the new x5 is a completely new
car says Mathis that's evident in the
design of the front end the radiator
grille is much steeper and here inside
the instrumentation is even more
oriented to the driver I really like
that
BMW is offering three different engines
our test vehicle the x5 30 DX drive is
equipped with a 6-cylinder diesel unit
that puts out 190 kilowatts and up to
560 Newton meters of torque
that's enough to hurl the car from 0 to
100 and 6.9 seconds plus the new engines
consume less fuel
Yamba danes product management spokesman
eels Christian Copa says the company has
significantly improved fuel efficiency
with all its models up to 17 percent
with the popular xDrive 30d the other
engines have made similar improvements
BMW is especially proud of the S Drive
25 d which produces just 149 grams of
co2 per kilometer or 5.6 liters of fuel
for 100 kilometers the x5 s appearance
has likewise been worked over the
headlights now extend all the way to
BMWs trademark kidney grille
the sculpted body with its distinctive
lines increases create a dramatic
interplay of light and shadow and make
the car look smaller than its 4.9 meter
or all length
inside occupants are surrounded by a
pleasant design horizontal lines connect
doors and the dashboard driver assist
systems include night vision that helps
identify people or animals while the new
parking assist offers both lengthwise
and lateral guidance the iDrive
controller includes a touchpad that can
recognize handwritten inputs
the remote boot release in the key is
standard equipment and the new x5 keeps
the split tailgate from the first
generation the rear seat backrest has
three segments for maximum flexibility
with the seats folded down the x5 offers
eighteen hundred and seventy liters of
storage space a hundred litres more than
his predecessor an optional third row
seats is also available as a sports
activity vehicle the x5 is conceived
mainly for paved roads so it made sense
to offer a rear wheel drive version as
christian kalfa says BMW gave a lot of
thought to the decision the company
wants to be successful in many markets
including regions where weather
conditions don't make X Drive a big deal
for countries that tax co2 emissions
restore your own gifts the all-wheel
drive models can handle fairly rough
terrain without too much effort and
here's the proof
to find out just what the x5 can do we
went off-road the two-ton car had no
problems with descents over loose rocks
and gravel and on uneven surfaces the
all-wheel drive distributes traction
effectively
even minor ditches are no obstacle a
gallop whether all-wheel drive or a
rear-wheel drive the new bmw x5 is sure
to find fans and although it's a
substantial car from the driver's seat
it feels remarkably easy to handle in
addition to the standard 8-speed
automatic the x5 also has an automatic
start/stop function that helps save fuel
also standard a driving style button
that adjusts the car two different ways
of driving since its introduction BMW
has sold 1.3 million x5 s we're pretty
sure the latest model will be just as
popular
you